[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au bout de mes rêves
[Applaudissements]
jusqu'au bout de mes rêves
[Musique]
j'irai jusqu'au bout
[Applaudissements]
pour la raison sa chaîne tout au bout de
mes rêves si vous passez
changer de
[Applaudissements]
terre
il adore
par contre toi quand tu chantes tu
trouves pas de
ça va au niveau des vannes ça va
généralement tu es pas mal ça parce que
c'est la vie
c'est bon
anecdotique
la dernière fois qu'il a chanté il a
trouvé Flavie flamand ça doit coûter 10
bars
[Rires]
ça va être compliqué
calme-toi pour l'instant c'est pas ton
tour qu'est-ce que tu veux une chanson
pour toi ma vie pour l'instant tu vas
fermer ta gueule
alors qu'est-ce que tu veux moi chef non
il met des pigeons sur balcon non non
non je la fais pas
mal allez pas mal c'est pas mal regardez
franchement là tout est cassé encore un
mec
ring
encore un match
d'angoisse sur ma vie j'ai une montée
d'angoisse sans déconner ça va toi tu as
de la lumière chez toi
tu fais des économies il y a rien qui
mange ensemble
[Applaudissements]
vraiment tu as fait ta valise tu as mis
toutes les affaires tu kiffais pour
partir en vacances il te restait que des
trucs un peu chelou non ça va pas du
tout ensemble mais toi ça va comme je te
dis ça correspond à ta personnalité
merci beaucoup tu es désordonné
allez c'est parti encore un matin vas-y
encore un matin assez si si ça démarre
comme ça
[Musique]
encore un matin un matin pour rien un
argile au creux de mes mains
encore un matin sans raison
laissez tomber ou résister
encore un matin qui cherche et qui doute
ce matin perdu cherche une
allez encore un matin du pire ou du
mieux à étain vous mettre le feu
attention
[Musique]
ça ne sert
à rien
[Musique]
ce matin
c'est le mien c'est le diable attention
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à Kelly
elle croit que les journées démarrent à
14h elle croit que les journées
commencent avec Faustine Bollaert
[Rires]
tu vas faire là-bas toi et toi tu feras
moi je sais plus rien
en plus c'est ton cas tu marches tout
seul
ça fait des années que tu marches au sol
c'est pour toi cette chanson allez c'est
parti c'est quoi avec nous chez vous il
est 17h50
c'est la folie
qu'est-ce qu'elle a choisi
est très long c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en haut des tours les voix se taisent
bien
réglée
camouf pour quelques heures les autres
[Musique]
entre la violence et la violence et
l'ennui je m'en sortirai
me le promet
des moyens légaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
règle du jeu fixé
comme il est beau
je te donne je te donne
l'anglais
c'est drôle
[Musique]
une épaule fragile solide à la fois ce
que j'imagine et ce que je crois
je te donne tout de mes différentes
tous ces défauts qui sont autant de
chance on sera jamais des standards des
gens bien comme il faut attention
je te donne ce que j'ai ce que je vends
à quelqu'un
[Musique]
que les routes sont laissés dans
l'histoire nos filles sont brûlés
sont nos trésor
je te donne toutes mes différences
de ses défauts qui sont au temps de
chance on s'agit ensemble des gens bien
comme il pourra toi vite
oh je te donne ce que je sais que je
vaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chez vous attention mesdames
c'est le meilleur moment attention
je te donne
que je suis
ma faute
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce que j'imagine et ce que je crois
les raisons qui me portent
[Musique]
une épée
je te donne tout le monde
[Musique]
très fort très fort
E
ici
[Musique]
c'est comme ça
côté neuf et sauvage
libre continent sans grillage
[Musique]
de nos rêves sont étroits
va te faire bouffer c'est pour ça que
j'irai là-bas c'est à toi
[Musique]
mais tout est possible à mon âge
si tu as la force et la foi
[Musique]
leur est à côté de tes doigts dans la
main
c'est pour ça que j'irai là-bas j'aurais
ma chance voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le feu les diables
je te sais si fragile parfois
[Musique]
et on est pas bien
la chanson s'appelle là-bas vous voulez
partir
en ce moment
c'est pour moi
[Applaudissements]
vous enflammez pas je l'ai pas encore
non c'est bon
ça me fait plaisir en plus elles sont
hyper bien alors qu'est-ce qu'il veut
lui alors moi j'ai je marche seul du
coup pas mal comme un bateau
de musique ou genre tu es arrivé comme
ça et genre tu chantais mais genre avec
mes pieds sur l'estrade il y avait une
estrade au lilas comme ça et genre elle
t'appelait comme ça elle faisait sur je
marche seul j'appelle Cyril Hanouna un
jour je suis arrivé elle m'a appelé
comas je suis monté sur les strades les
meufs comme des folles
les meufs ensemble mon frère les mecs
Stéphane Galati comment comme un ouf il
y avait Sofiane radouani comme un ouf
que je t'ai chant ouais Cyril tout le
monde était comme des oufs et là tu vois
je suis arrivé mon frère mal prof elle
s'appelait madame kerency je me rappelle
mon frère écoute-moi bien et tu jettes
un prof elle a répondu non n'importe
quoi
elle a répondu elle a répondu mettez-la
[Musique]
ça me rappelle pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comme un bateau des
je marche dans la ville
[Applaudissements]
tout seul
ce sont des paysages je suis les jeux de
ça mais ça ne s'achète pas je m'en fous
je m'en fous
de tout de ces gènes qui forment à nos
cours je m'enfuis
un sourire
[Musique]
sans les rues qui se donnent
à lui me pardonne je marche seul
[Musique]
on oubliant les heures je marche seul
je marche seul
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai été médisante mais elle vous va
tellement bien
M6
où je reprends au deuxième couplet
où je le reprends pas depuis le début
remettez remettez
[Rires]
n'hésitez pas n'hésitez pas sur les
réseaux si la voix de Jean-Jacques
Goldman vous gêne
[Musique]
depuis le début
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment vas-tu
[Applaudissements]
j'en profite d'ailleurs j'aimerais que
vous passiez cette phrase chez vous
n'importe comment vous filmez c'est à
dire que vous demandez un pain au
chocolat qu'est-ce que vous voulez
j'ai les poils partout j'ai les poils
partout chez les poils partout partout
merci